salut mes petits écrou s'allumer petit
boulon enfin d'affaires fait nouveau
casse tête aujourd'hui sur la chaîne si
vous n'avez pas compris pourquoi je dis
ça au départ je vous recommande de
regarder le dernier casse tête en date
sur la chaîne et il ya eu un fort débat
sur les écrous les bourdons et et quand
la vidéo est sorti il y en a beaucoup
qui me l'ont dit jeudi à 15 je savais
pas et depuis je crois je le sais bien
je sais bien bien bien mais vraiment si
je me suis trompé
n'hésitez pas à me le dire aujourd'hui
on attaque une série de castaluna et
demandé que ça continue les cassettes on
continue une vidéo sur trois en moyenne
sera un casse tête parce qu'on regarde
le mentalisme quand même sur la chaîne
ça peut le but du jeu en général ce sont
les vidéos qui sortent le mercredi à 6
heures puisque c'est une vidéo tous les
mercredis à 6 heures sur la chaîne mais
de temps en temps il ya des bonus en
plus le lundi au vendredi ou samedi sur
du mentalisme
cette nouvelle série de casses têtes que
nous allons attaquer c'est sur un
concept qui m'a beaucoup plu c'est super
lourd d'ailleurs ce sont des pièces des
chéquiers
donc là on a un fou et un cavalier sur
les lisières chevalier sûr que j'allais
du chevalier j'ai eu pas mal de
commentaires c'est alors un fou ou un
chevalier vedène on ne sait pas
chocolatines par le chocolat waouh
bon je redeviens sérieux quelques
secondes ce sont de belles pièces en
métal
il y en a toute une série a aussi droit
à la dame la tour le pion et là j'en ai
pris deux mais si j'arrive allait
craquer assez vite j'en ferai un
troisième si c'est trop galère dans
cracks et un jean frais qu'un seul et
puis une fois temps en temps je
reprendrai les pillages et pas faire
toutes les pièces d'affilée parce qu'il
avait trop long mais là pour aujourd'hui
j'ai envie d'attaquer au moins l'une des
deux et puis aussi je voulais vous
remercier de quelque chose on est
complet pour le zinc à tout ce que
j'avais à dire sur le sujet merci
beaucoup et rendez vous durant la
tournée pour tous les autres liens
description bon on commence avec le fou
ou avec le cavalier c'est loïc qui va
décider
loïc avec le chevalier avec le chevalier
ok je checke doha et j'enlève le fou en
fait j'avais envie de commencer par le
fou avec le fils en a maintenant je
respecte le cavalier alors ce petit
place d'exploration rapide mais en fait
juste en sortant de la boîte ça je n'ai
pas vraiment compris
c'est à dire que on a un cavalier qui
est vraiment en une seule pièce de métal
mais ici en bas grâce à un système de
boulons et d'écrous le big three de
cette partie là qui tourne ok elle
tourne ça fait pas grand-chose fait
qu'elle tourne donc j'imagine qu'il va
falloir faire des mouvements et oui mais
il ya vraiment rien d'autre qui bouge en
fait strictement rien mais c'est joli un
parent contraint d'avoir un jeu d'échec
c'est le chase puzzle knight
de quoi suffire à l'accent ça donne
n'est ce pas c'est un ayama qui fabrique
ça apparemment loïc est ce que tu peux
nous dire comment s'appellent ces
puzzles le chef puzzle et night you
can't be do what we ou en tout doux
exactement quand même bossé cet axe en
rond il faut un mec bilingue
blague à part puisque puisqu'il ya juste
le bis comme ça je pense vraiment qu'il
ya un système de 2,2 de mouvement en
faisant d'autres mouvements c'est pas
clair hier de rotation quelque part
parce que sinon je vais pouvoir bisséous
dévissé jusqu'à l'infini
ça va c'est apache en a ok là je pense
que c'est ce qui devrait s'ouvrir
parce que quand je le tourne ça fait ch
quand cooke je me tiens je sais pas si
ça vous allez le voir avec la caméra du
dessus mais regardez juste au niveau de
l'encoche là quand je les tournées on
sent que voilà là je sais comme si
j'allais sortir il ya quelque chose qui
le retient et qui je pense qu'il retient
de l'autre côté ça doit retenir ici en
face parce que tous élevés sauf là à
l'intérieur de chaque pièce apparemment
de chaque pièce d'échec il ya une petite
pièce qui est le symbole de la marque et
le but du jeu c'est toujours de libérer
cette petite pièce
ouais si c'est ça il ya vraiment une
encoche alors du coup on va essayer de
se la jouer the sentinel
ceux qui sont nés dans les années 80
connaissent alors ça c'est un vrai souci
en fait j'entends en faisant ça la
petite pièce qu'on doit libérer et le
fait qu'elle vous
d ans un gars fassent du bruit ça
m'empêche d'entendre ce qui pourrait se
passer d'autres à l'intérieur
alors ça c'est pas la pièce bien tout
petits bruits donc un tout petit quelque
chose métallique également qui se
déplace dedans et si je mets plus
d'amplitude là j'entends la pièce
entendez-vous la pièce oui on ne
l'entend bien ok donc il doit y avoir un
petit butoir ici et là vu que ça appelé
choc là comme ça claque
forcément c'est que oui voilà c'est
qu'il ya une encoche est quelque chose
qui se placent dans l'encoche donc je
vais je mettre déjà en position de dans
l'encoche là où on sent que ça pourrait
s'ouvrir ce qui me permet de vous si je
fais une bonne chose quelque chose
d'intéressant que ça puisse me venir
dans les mains sans que je comprenne
sûrement pourquoi ça a marché ou pas
[Musique]
mais non ça peut pas être ça la solution
je suis sûr que non c'est impossible que
ce soit ça ça veut pas être le fait de
taper deux fois non non j'en peux plus
des castes et tous fait taper à mes
jolies c'est ça la petite pièce haye a
marqué chevalier dessus et un fer à
cheval
attends je suis en fait je suis pas
d'accord du tout donc là ici là il ya la
petite encoche que j'imaginais qu'elle a
hélas on a bien un petit butoir amovible
d'ailleurs là il est complètement lâche
me dit c'est impossible que ce soit en
tant que jeu les libérer en fait c'est
un peu possible mais je refuse d'y
croire non mais je pense que non moi je
pense pas du coup cette ville comment
comme ça alors là du coup là du coup je
peux plus bon ça c'est remis sans que je
comprenne pourquoi ça se remet ça c'est
génial
des mouvements que j'avais fait juste
avant c'était une rotation vers l'avant
ok et là est ce que du coup je peux
lever ou l'ouvrir ou pas oui d'accord ok
et si je le remet maintenant et que je
fais mais dont une rotation vers
l'arrière là je te plus d'accord si je
fais une relation sur le côté je ne peux
plus mais je me souviens qu'au départ
j'ai fait une rotation vers l'avant
passionné vous aussi pour cette vidéo
et je peux ok donc c'est clairement ça
pour ouvrir le casse tête
là c'est bloqué il faut faire une
rotation complète du cavalier comme ça
vers l'avant qui doit faire un petit
système qui libère ce qui bloque
l'espèce de petits de petits bitonio
comtois là et si on refait à bastien je
le fais essayer de le faire sans si je
refais la rotation vers du coup
l'arrière
il est complètement bloqué le petit by
tonio est complètement bloquée si
j'applique dessus peuvent plus rentrer
je sais pas comment ça se passe dedans
mais c'est quand même hyper ingénieux
alors que si je fais vers l'avant un
tour complet alors là il est
complètement mobile très cool pas très
dur on va pas se mentir mais très cool
et pas très dur parce que au final j'ai
fait à l'envers parce que comme au final
il y avait que là qu'on avait une
liberté de mouvement bon ok c'est
craquer ok comme d'habitude je vous
ferai les gros plan un petit peu de tout
ça sur instagram de dans les jeux tv ou
dans les story vous pouvez rajouter à
l'instar grade c'est celui ci c'est dans
description c'est au dessus on est
maintenant 55 milles qu'attendez vous
pour nous rejoindre
timmins star mais je n'oublie pas le
trim snap deuxième casse tête
le fou donc le fou pareil en l'ouvrant
forcément j'ai bien senti que la le bas
ça se manipuler et exactement comme
lecavalier je sens là un système
d'encoches qui est ici là juste là c'est
ici juste là je pense
elle se trouve
et nous pouvons constater que ce petit
nez ce tir comme ceux ci ainsi que
pinocchio regarde c'est comme pinocchio
à la place à un plat par exemple les
youtuber s'en fiche
qu'on laisse un pouce bleu ou pas c'est
un mensonge son nez s'allonge
est-ce que ça de l'importance bah oui et
du coup ça se remplit voilà c'est les
espèces de biais cognitif de d'avoir
réussi le cavalier il ya quelques
secondes j'ai envie de vous dire je vais
le tourner vers l'avant et voir si ça
marche
bon ben ça marche pas mais heureusement
que ça ne marche pas mais je vais
essayer par l'arrière et on ne leur a
jamais cette phrase du texte et ça ne
marche pas non plus bien sûr mais
peut-être que sur le côté
quand j'entends jean pierre la petite
pièce qui se baladent jetez plus et de
l'autre côté
non mais alors peut-être dans les
commentaires vous êtes en train de lire
mais fabien tu es un peu stupide tu
viens de nous dire au départ qu'il y
avait ça y est tu t'en sers pas c'est
vrai je viens de m'en rendre compte
alors comment je pourrais m'en servir
comme ceci
j'ai entendu un vrai truc en fait il ya
changé quand je les retourne et déjà
tirer ça tout le long du corps ça fait
comme si quelque chose d 110 ap le coq
est ce que je veux dire ça leur fait
plus
[Musique]
je me dis que comme le fou c'est fait
pour sortir en diagonale si ça se trouve
il ya un truc avec le fait de le mettre
en diagonale tu vois ce que je veux dire
ouais quand je m'engage à bonal là on
voit que ça ça touche tout ça comme tout
à l'heure c'est plus collé collé comme
c'est plus collé collé à ce que dia et
bien oui est ce que le oui nous avons
une petite pièce laquelle et s est bien
c'est celle du fou évidemment et c'est
celle de oui le bishop le fou quand j'ai
déjà connu il était facile suit la voir
il était facile n'étaient pas si dures
en fait ça récupère la même logique je
sais pas si c'est le cas pour tous mais
là j'ai la même encore qu'on avait sur
le cavalier et là j'ai un petit bitonio
alors là quand sortie ouverte alors que
ça ces sorties donc j'étais comme ça je
me dis ah oui d'accord cécile le fou
regarde vers moi et s'ils regardent plus
vers moi et j'ai appuyé d'accord ça
ressort et c'est complètement solide et
lui il touche ici et si je le remets
vers moi et que je fais ça là il est en
position ouvert on va dire et donc là je
pourrai le ranger est donc ça ça
voudrait dire que si je fais ça à l'art
dans tout ça c'était un oui il est
inscrite et là de son sourire donc
plaque là il a dû ressortir et lâche peu
plus lourd et j'espère que cette vidéo
vous a plu alors exceptionnellement j'ai
pas commencé en faisant une intro d'un
autre youtuber d'ailleurs très drôle est
ce que tu dis les commentaires loïc non
et bien vallée lire parce que tout l'été
à chaque fois je reprenais l'intro de
youtube heures pour faire un casse tête
c'était un peu le concept
j'avais toujours des gens qui me disent
mais tu sais que tu ferais même intro
que machin donc on reprendra ce délire
là mercredi prochain à 6 heures vous
avez dans la description mon site
internet
avec toutes les dates du spectacle en
tournée là à partir de demain par
exemple je suis à toulouse pour trois
jours allez voir vos villes là vous
pouvez vous abonner là vous pouvez
regarder la vidéo que j'ai sorti ce
lundi
en bonus sur comment devenir un génie
parce que vous êtes des génies vous le
savez pas et moi je vous embrasse
à très bientôt k o